New Orleans overnight removed the second
of four Confederate monuments in the
city crews took down a statue of
Confederate President Jefferson Davis
Lee's flooded the area to separate the
rival protesters shel Miller's at the
site where the monument stood for more
than a century Michelle good morning
good morning dozen stood out here to
witness an action conceived two years
ago after the racially motivated
killings of nine people in Charleston
South Carolina that state took down its
most visible symbols of the Confederacy
it's been a much tougher task for this
city to do so this morning crews
dismantled the statue of Confederate
President Jefferson Davis removing it
from the spot where it stood for more
than a century these particular
monuments were put up by a particular
group of people for a particular purpose
and the purpose is well the purpose was
really to whitewash history and to tell
a sanitized version of the Confederacy
the monuments were built to memorialize
general robert e lee Confederate
President Jefferson Davis and general PT
Beauregard in the years following the
Civil War they're not necessarily heroes
of mine now heroes of anybody still
businessman Frank Stewart took out a two
page ad in a local newspaper advocating
the statue should remain Stewart did
back the removal several weeks ago of
the Liberty Monument a monolith
celebrating an anti police riot by white
supremacists in 1874 that part of
history and I really don't think that
anybody should have the privilege of
changing history because history is
truth many are on the sidelines watching
the heated rhetoric niganda Lewis is an
associate professor of african-american
studies at Tulane University it is
primarily our inability to have honest
dialogue about race will these monuments
being taken down make a difference if
we're not going to commit to the
dialogue it's not going to make a
difference just yesterday a judge denied
the latest efforts to saw the removal of
these statues on the grounds that the
city didn't own them the mayor called
that a Hail Mary pass that didn't work
Nora such an interesting debate there
Michelle thank you so much